[Music]
ah good
and
Oh
the bag with a little deformed box on
was waiting simon yes if my family there
it's natural there is a very very big
respect between him and me she is arguing
often the cli of his decisions he does not
ask besides the question is what
I think it's good that he does
something or even thing
[Music]
sauna
his breast so I'm trying to piece together
a small family unit for two
conflict month for children
on law and I do not see them
often we live and friends from here on
weekend
[Music]
of course as everyone gets
knew
the demand story of kurdistan
the history of iraq a sphere of
Saddam Hussein and his young boys who
are the age of my grandchildren
arrive and the war and after a long
difficult journey torn from their
culture have realized that even in the
worst circumstances have always made
with a small light to which we
must go
[Music]
I really wish it's really there
who grows with what they've learned
in this long in this long journey
initiatic return home and
develop their country and succeed life
is there really I would be happy
to go to Kurdistan
[Music]